most of these looks that he's wearing
he's got the hat he's always got the
iconic hat shape and he's always got the
long
the long tassels hanging off the arms
it's like a cowboy pimp
right okay no so let's go back
you got to remember about where we were
but i'll do this part now
okay he's wearing glasses
i say oh let's make let's put some crap
on the glasses and make them crazy
that the macho man would wear so i start
putting all the stuff on the glasses and
i'm working on glasses
then he says to me listen
uh they made me the macho king
and i got to wear a crown
and he doesn't like it i said okay
he says i need something else for my
head but let's get
i don't want to wear this crown anymore
that they gave me i said fine
we go to ebor city there's a proper
men's hat store
with every kind of hat you could think
of english bowler
you know just all kind of things through
history
every different kind of hat you could
imagine and there's cowboy hats there
too
i say oh the shape of the cowboy hat's
good on them let's see this
and so we try this try that now we end
up with straw hats
you know i'm buying them by the dozen um
in his size and i'm painting them and
i'm having
covered with fabric um i'm doing all
kind of crazy stuff
or i'm i'm painting them and then i'm
making a band that goes around them
but
what i'm saying to you is that the other
wrestlers
let's say jake the snake he's got one
snake one costume
that's the deal you know you see it next
year it's the same thing
randy you're seeing some crazy ass
outfit every
single week and the outfits
fit this character you can't say why i
can't give you the words but it fits
this character
and i'm making the clothes
and he's getting over with the clothes
when he's saying to me
i'm small what i'm saying to you is when
he came
out of that dressing room now he's with
the boys
if the boys are standing up he's just
what you said
short compared to the big show andre the
giant whatever
hulk yeah they're all taller than him
right so
but his personality
is much stronger than theirs his
macho mania crazed thing
where he's living in that place this is
not
you know he's living there
and his mother his proper jewish mother
who comes with him sometimes the mother
and father come really
oh yeah oh yeah how old was he when you
were when you guys were doing i don't
know i'm bad on time i'd have to sit and
think about it
you're wasting your time asking me about
that i mean i got no thing on
right right but the mother comes
and she sit and brings the dog and the
father's there
whatever you know he's having to come
like every two three weeks
you know and they want to see what he's
doing or whatever
the mother's the one who's came up with
the name macho man
oh really yeah oh really um
it's a proper jewish lady and she says
to me
that he
as a high school kid would get up really
early in the morning go practice whether
it's baseball or football or soccer or
what you know i don't
i don't know what they're playing but he
and then he'd come back home clean up go
to school
but he was like so intensely into this
and didn't fool around with the girls
he was working the whole time now and
again a little bit with the girls but
he was working hard hard hard and i'm
saying to you that
miss elizabeth and
gorgeous george both complained no day
off
no i mean he's out of balance he's
working hard hard hard
and you'll hear this at times from
people who
[Music]
are very accomplished at what they do
uh daryl hall i heard him say it you
know you could say well there's
50 great songwriters here 50 great
singers 50 great guitar players or
you know arrangers or whatever why's
this guy got
30 songs that the whole world know and
this guy's got two
this one works harder that's what daryl
is saying meaning
and it's his nature right to work hard
he learned it from his parents
the same macho man learned it from his
parents go and break your ass
work hard this is life this is what
we're telling you to do
and he did it um
you're saying where do these things come
from
[Music]
i'm saying back to you um
in my shop pull it back a little farther
there you go right there
i'm in my shop i get a telephone call
hi this is such and such advertising
agency in connecticut stanford
connecticut
you know no one calls me like this what
are you who
uh we're gonna have
macho man push our product slim jim
like i know what a slim jim i'm a
vegetarian since 1970.
are you really yeah and i saw
slim jim in the store but i don't know
what it is i don't know that it's dried
meat
it's a fine piece of meat i don't know
anything about it
so they say well this is slim jim we
want you to make clothes for
randy for slim jim commercials and this
and that
and i say okay and they say there's 12
of us or nine of us sitting around this
table
we can all hear you and i say okay
i said tell me what what colors you want
it to be and what do you want it to be
they're drawing a blank i said okay let
me start talking
how about we do three outfits
in the using the three colors that are
in your product
black red and yellow okay we got that
so they'll be predominantly black and
you know
this one's more yellow this one's more
black but this one's more red they'll
all go with each other
okay i said the next thing i need i said
i need only one person to call me on the
telephone
and communicate with me i'm not talking
to a group of people later
just give me one person to talk to i
said in 10
send me 10 grand or 5 grand i don't know
what i said to get started
um and now again
i got a free ride to make
macho man crazy but with these colors to
be used in a commercial
for slim jim what you tried to say is
how the hell did you come up with
this or how did you come up with this
you know i just have some idea at some
part in my head who knows let's try this
you know we'll change the lettering or
we'll do this this way or
i'll start raggeding that but you
weren't worried about like what if this
idea isn't good enough because he
you just were constantly making him new
things this is a great point you're
bringing up
the point is is that like what if he
doesn't want to pay for this
outfit like you were never worried about
that you had you had an infinite this is
paid for
forget that yeah so now we're talking
about freedom
to be creative and the freedom is
that you're making clothes for the macho
man
the the work is how many outfits can you
come up with
in a year that are cool not
might he he never told me he didn't like
something in his life
ever ever didn't even hint at it like it
this is not up to the
you know and he would put on outfits
we had a mirror leaning up against the
wall he put on the outfits
there's a a junk chair
comfortable foam next to the mirror
elizabeth would sit in it he'd come out
of the dressing
area come over look at himself in the
mirror he says
oh i'm gonna wear this to wrestlemania
you know
now he'd go now we're on the third
outfit he says
wow this is cool i'm gonna wear this to
wrestlemania
you